we are just about a day away from super
bowl 56 and people here in las vegas are
gearing up but looks like some are
having some trouble stocking up for the
big game madison kimbrough spoke with
local shoppers today she joins us live
with more madison
yeah we spoke to shoppers here at the
smiths and while the majority of them
were here for valentine's day we did
find some super bowl fans who were fully
aware of the supply chain shortage
some of the top game day foods include
chicken wings avocados and beer all of
which are priced higher nowadays due to
inflation the highest in recent history
according to the u.s bureau of labor
statistics and you may have noticed even
when dining out many restaurants are out
of certain items or your favorite dish
is priced higher labor shortages and an
increase in consumer demand just some of
the reasons behind this here's what some
local shoppers had to say about
availability in stores as they gear up
for game day i completely expected to
come in here today and not get
everything i wanted it seemed like bacon
was
in short supply the beer supply was
kind of low the national retail
federation announced that shoppers will
spend 14.6 billion on food drinks
apparel and decorations and other items
for this year's big game that's up from
13.9 billion dollars spent last year
and the biggest item on people's list
for tomorrow's game from the shoppers we
spoke to it seems to be meat beans and
dip now according to the national retail
federation 90 million people are
expected to either attend or throw a
super bowl party that's up from 27
million from last year reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now